نحن الخضار نحن الخضار بالخير
ناتي للصغار
نحن الخضار نحن الخضار للخير
خيار خيار كلكم بار
ما احلى لون الاخضر
طازج مفيد للهض
خيال
[تصفيق]
بصل بصل
انا بين الخضري بطل
انا في المطبخ انا الكل
بصل
[موسيقى]
نحن الخضر
فار لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا بالخير
ناتي للصغار
طماطم طماطم توميتو
اصلحوا خضرا وفواكه
طماطم طماطم توميتوا
حمراء ووجودي مهم
طماطم
قرنبيط قولي فلور
لوني ابيض واخضر
[موسيقى]
قرنبيط قولي فلاور
تاكل مي حتى ستكبر
قرنبيط
نحن الخضار نحن الخضار بالخير
ناتي للصغار
جزر جزر كيرات
انا اقوي النظر
[موسيقى]
جزر جزر
الدنيا والقمر
جز
اء
بطاطس بطاطس بوتيتو
انا رائعه محبوبه
بطاطس بطاطس
وبالاطباق مطلوبه
بطاطس بوتيتو
[موسيقى]
لالالالالا
نحن الخضر نحن الخضار
[موسيقى]
ناتي للصغار